I HOPE YOU ARE OUT ON SUNDAY.
I HOPE EVERY BUDDY STAY SAFE.
YOU TAKE CARE.
AS THE NUMBER OF CORONAVIRUS
INFECTIONS RISE COME UP
MAYOR de BLASIO PUTTING
NEW YORK CITY INTO A STATE OF
EMERGENCY.
>> IN LIGHT OF ALL THOSE
CHANGING REALITIES, IT IS TIME
TO DECLARE A STATE OF EMERGENCY
IN NEW YORK CITY WHERE OVER 500
PEOPLE WOULD GATHER, PARADES,
RALLIES, SPORTS EVENTS,
PROFESSIONAL CONFERENCES,
ET CETERA WILL NOW NO LONGER
HAVE GATHERINGS.
I UNFORTUNATELY SUSPECT THAT
WILL BE A NUMBER OF MONTHS.
>> Laura: MY NEXT GUEST LEAD
NEW YORK CITY THROUGH ITS LAST
GREAT CRISIS, SEPTEMBER 11TH.
RUDY GIULIANI, FORMER
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR JOINS ME
NOW.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
IF de BLASIO, IT’S A COMPLEX
SERIES OF DECISIONS YOU HAVE TO
MAKE.
BUT HE SAID MONTHS, IS THAT THE
RIGHT MOVE?
>> ON DECLARING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY, I WOULDN’T
SECOND-GUESS HIM.
I AM SURPRISED THAT HE HASN’T
BEEN AROUND FOR MONTHS THE
PRESIDENT HAS CRITICIZED HE WAS
INVOLVED IN THIS IN DECEMBER,
de BLASIO WAS I GUESS SLEEPING
WHICH IS WHAT HE USUALLY DOES.
THE GOVERNOR I ACTUALLY WROTE A
NOTE PRAISING THE GOVERNOR FOR
GETTING ON TOP OF THIS.
FOR FIVE
WEEKS AGO, I DIDN’T SEE
DE BLASIO AT ALL.
I HELD A PRESS CONFERENCE THE
NEXT DAY WHEN WE HAD A VIRUS IN
NEW YORK CITY, ON SATURDAY AND
HELD A PRESS CONFERENCE EVERY
DAY UNTIL WE GOT CONTROL OF
WEST NILE VIRUS.
THIS GUY IS FOR FIVE WEEKS LATE.
IS HE RIGHT?
HE HAS LEAD TO STATISTICS, I
WILL NOT SECOND-GUESS IT.
HE DOESN’T KNOW IT IS GOING TO
BE MONTHS, THAT IS IT TERRIBLE
MISTAKE.
YOU TELL PEOPLE THE TRUTH, AND
THEN YOU LEAVE THEM WITH A SENSE
OF HOPE.
TONS OF NUMBER 11, THE WORST DAY
IN THE HISTORY, I FINISHED IT BY
SAYING THE PEOPLE OF NEW YORK
ARE GOING TO COME OUT OF THIS,
AND THEY WILL COME OUT OF IT
STRONGER.
THAT IS AFTER I HONESTLY
DESCRIBED TO THEM HOW
DEVASTATING EVERYTHING WAS.
THAT ISN’T A LEADER, THAT’S A
GUY -- FIRST OF ALL, WAY TOO
LATE -- HE IS RUNNING FOR THE
FIRE, AND THE FIRE HAS ALREADY
DESTROYED HALF THE BUILDING.
EVERYBODY ELSE HAS BEEN THERE
AND HE WANTS TO GET ON IT.
JUST A SIMPLE MISTAKE LIKE THAT,
FOR MANY MONTHS.
IT MAY BE MANY MONTHS, IT MAY BE
A FEW WEEKS.
A STATE OF EMERGENCY IS A VERY,
VERY SERIOUS THING TO DO.
>> Laura: RUDY, I THINK ONE OF
OUR FRIENDS AT SPN SAID THIS
YESTERDAY.
YOU DO HAVE TO THINK LONG TERM
WHILE YOU DEAL WITH A SHORT-TERM
PROBLEM, YOU CAN’T COMPLETELY
THROW OUT THE WINDOW THE
LONG-TERM IMPLICATIONS OF THE
PRECEDENT THAT WE ARE SETTING IN
THE UNITED STATES EVERY TIME A
PATHOGEN ESCAPES FROM A FOREIGN
COUNTRY.
CHINA IS NOT NECESSARILY OUR
GREAT FRIEND, EVERYTHING IS
GOING TO SHUTDOWN IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT IS A WEAPON, THAT BECOMES A
WEAPON IN AND OF ITSELF TO
SOMEONE WITH BAD MOTIVES.
THAT IS WHAT I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT.
>> IT IS ONE OF THE REASONS I
TRY VERY HARD TO GET
NEW YORK CITY AWAKE AGAIN RIGHT
AFTER SEPTEMBER 11TH.
I WANTED TO SAY TO THE
TERRORISTS, YOU CAN’T COME HERE
WE CAN TAKE SOME RISKS.
ARE NOT GOING TO RUIN OUR
ECONOMY.
THERE WAS A BEAUTIFUL ARTICLE IN
THE DAILY NEWS POINTING OUT THAT
I GOT BROADWAY BACK TWO WEEKS
FASTER THAN THEY WANT TO DO, I
GOT THEM BACK FOR A SPECIFIC
PURPOSE.
THEY WANT MAKING ANY MONEY, BUT
THEY WERE PERFORMING EVERY NIGHT
AND EVENTUALLY THEY ALL CAME
BACK.
YES, LEADERSHIP REQUIRES GIVING
PEOPLE A BALANCE.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE THEM WHAT THEY
NEED TO BE SAFE, BUT YOU ALSO
HAVE TO GIVE THEM WHAT THEY NEED
TO BE REALISTIC AND HOPEFUL.
de BLASIO BLEW IT IN TWO WAYS,
HE IS TOO LATE.
>> Laura: WE MADE THAT POINT.
>> I KNOW I MADE IT, JUST A
LITTLE MORE.
HE WENT YOU’RE NOT ON MY RADIO
SHOW, THIS IS CABLE-TV.
RUDY, THEY ARE SAYING THIS IS
WORTH THE NINE.
PEOPLE LIKE JOE SCARBOROUGH,
PEOPLE ARE SAYING, JON MEACHAM
SAYING THAT THIS COULD LEAD TO A
DEPRESSION.
>> HOW DOES HE KNOW THAT?
>> Laura: AT THIS IS WHAT IS
SENDING PEOPLE TO THE GROCERY
STORE TO BUY 100 PALLETS OF
WATER.
>> THERE IS NO WAY TO KNOW
WHETHER IT WOULD LEAD TO A
DEPRESSION, WHETHER IN SOME WAYS
THERE COULD BE CONFLICTING
THINGS THAT HELP THE ECONOMY,
MONEY AND HEALTH CARE AND EVERY
THING ELSE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE OVERESTIMATED
9/11, I DIDN’T.
I OVERESTIMATED THE ESTIMATE.
I DIDN’T CONSIDER ALL OF THE
RELIEF WORK THAT WAS GOING TO BE
DONE THAT PUMPED UP THE ECONOMY
AND CREATED JOBS IN OTHER AREAS.
THESE ARE PREDICTIONS THAT ARE
MADE FROM BIAS.
NOT FROM INTELLIGENCE.
>> Laura: WE NEED TRANSPARENCY
AND FACTS AND HOPE.
AND SOMETIMES, EVERY NOW AND
THEN SOME HUMOR.
I THINK WE NEED THAT TOO.
>> AND A LACK OF PANDERING WOULD